batfleck has officially sent his cape
and cowl to the cleaners and flown out
of Wayne Manor speaking during his
appearance on the Thursday February 14th
episode of Jimmy Kimmel Live Ben Affleck
finally came forward and explained in no
uncertain terms why he is no longer
playing Batman
I'm not Batman unlike the circumstances
surrounding and sequence of events
leading up to a blacks departure from
the coveted comic book character role
his actual reason for ditching the post
is surprisingly not complex in the
slightest he simply couldn't craft an
iteration of the Dark Knight that he was
happy with for the forthcoming
standalone film the Batman
just kind of couldn't come up with a
version the couldn't crack it and so I
thought it was like you know time to let
someone else take a shot at a Plex ties
to the DC extended universe and to his
role as Batman that he originated in
2016's Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice have been frayed for over two
years now after taking turns in Justice
League and Suicide Squad Affleck was
eyeing a sparkly new project a
standalone pic entitled the Batman that
he was originally slated to write direct
and lead announced in July of 2015 those
initial grand plans for the Batman began
to fall apart when a pike backed out of
his position as director handing the
reins to Wharf of the Planet of the Apes
filmmaker Matt Reeves after coming to
the tough realization that he didn't
have the wherewithal to work behind the
camera and act in front of it without
sacrificing quality in one of the two
jobs a human being can only absorb so
much applix said in late January of 2017
performing this role demands focus
passion and the very best performance I
can give it has become clear that I
cannot do both jobs to the level they
require together with the studio I have
decided to find a partner in a director
who will collaborate with me on this
massive film at the time Warner Brothers
assured that the studio supported a flex
decision not to direct the Batman and
remained quote committed to working with
him to bring a standalone Batman picture
to life flash forward to July of 2018
when deadline issued a report claiming a
plaque was well and truly done with the
Batman and wouldn't be reprising his
role again just a few months later The
Hollywood Reporter published its own
peace report
the actor was indeed leaving the DCE you
something tells me we're not getting the
band back together
this all brings us to now a time in
which there is no actor attached to lead
the Batman no star standing firm in the
DC movie world as Bruce Wayne this isn't
to say that Reeves has no idea what to
do with the film without a plaque in tow
or that Warner Brothers as well of
contenders for the new Batman is dry
it's quite the opposite really
several big-name stars are reportedly in
consideration to take over for a plaque
in the Batman from Robert Pattinson and
Kit Harington - Armie Hammer and Aaron
taylor-johnson
I want to team up like Batman and Robin
things are looking just as bright for
Reeves who has a clear vision of what
the Batman will feel like he previously
teased to The Hollywood Reporter that he
intends to cast a collection of
characters from Batman's massive rogues
gallery okay are you making some of
those up nope they're all real Reeves
also said that the film is heavily
inspired by film noir saying it's very
much a point-of-view driven noir Batman
tale it's told very squarely on his
shoulders and I hope it's going to be a
story that will be thrilling but also
emotional it's more Batman in his
Detective Mode than we've seen in the
films the comics have a history of that
he's supposed to be the world's greatest
detective and that's not necessarily
been a part of what the movies have been
no matter who ends up donning the bat
suit next it sounds like a plaque is in
good spirits over the situation and that
Reeves is confident in his ideas for the
Batman Warner Brothers has the film
slated to premiere in theaters on June
25th 2021 plenty of time to select a
fresh face to become the next Batman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you